your little brother who eats in the area is that
likes
I want to sink by photo very well
so so
as a mom of tranquility
which I have is very very strong
punctually on tires change that can
play can only turn on the television
can with the brothers share a
moment to put music to tell what
did you have a joke with gaby today
You can take the device to school
raise your hand and talk to the
device the jean louis companions
Pawn talk and talk with Tony with
the look that changed and the self-esteem of
she
he got stronger
the tobi that he no longer used knew thirty thousand
euros
today it came out and 13 thousand euros but good not
all families can access
then the social works and the state
has to give support because this changes
radically the life of a person and
a family and society as a whole